I do think that we do lead fairly
repressed buttoned-down lives and along
comes the drag queen and says [ __ ] all
that
hi I'm fat Russell for reason TV today
we're talking with Fenton Bailey in our
studios in Los Angeles California with
his partner Randy Barbado
Fenton Bailey founded the world of
wonder entertainment company in 1991
since then world of wonder has produced
scores of films and television programs
that have brazenly violated the taboos
of mainstream American popular culture
their documentaries and reality programs
have shown Americans inside the world of
the pornography industry prostitution
and transgender people their show
RuPaul's Drag Race a reality competition
series featuring drag queens has been a
hit on the logo Network and was recently
renewed for its sixth season recently
world of wonder celebrated its 21st
anniversary with the publication of a
book called the world according to
wonder 1991 to 2012 thanks for joining
us that much thanks I have me so I want
to ask you first why did you start
making films and television and what did
you want to accomplish with it I think
you know what really inspired us was
this thing called public access which
back in the day cable providers had to
make available channels to the public if
they wanted to run the cable in a city
they had to provide two public access
channels and they operated on a
first-come first-served basis so all the
crazy people out there could make their
own TV and have it shown on TV and we
found this treasure trove of crazy shows
that bore no relation to anything you
would see on commercial TV and that was
really inspiring to us it was this sort
of era of sort of anyone can do it it
was a slightly Punk thing and TV always
seems so locked down and regulated
whether it's commercial considerations
or education considerations and this was
just TV that had no motive it was just
crazy anarchic stuff and it was that was
totally what inspired us we were like oh
gosh we want to do this too so until
then you know television was the three
networks and
yes right and then since then we've had
the proliferation of cable networks
deregulation has allowed many many
voices on television aids I've noticed
that people often bemoan that the number
of choices they'll say oh my god now
there's 500 channels right who's that a
good thing or a bad thing for you oh you
know it's totally a good thing you know
Bruce Springsteen right 57 channels and
nothing's on well it's not true there's
a lot on and the more channels the more
voices and the more different faces that
you're going to get to see and so even
though yes there is some valid criticism
that a lot of television is the same and
mimics itself the fact of the matter is
there are voices now on TV that wouldn't
have been on TV simply weren't on TV 20
years ago I mean back in the day the
idea of a drag queen on TV was some sort
of unimaginable horror
it just wouldn't happen but you know
drag queens are perfect for TV because
they they leap out of the screen and
when we are pitching shows these days
you know all the executives that
networks are always like saying we all
characters characters that leap out of
the small screen you know people who can
have big impact even though it you know
small screen big impact so I have to
tell you a story I you know when I first
heard about you many years ago a friend
of mine told me about you and he's a gay
man and he said they're great they do
all these wonderful shows they're very
gay I was wondering I was wondering you
know do you take that as a compliment an
insult is that a good thing does it mean
anything to you
it doesn't really I mean it's we are gay
yes
I mean how gay I didn't know those
really a sliding scale of gayness I mean
it's like it's a sliding scale of
pregnancy I think you are or you aren't
you know he thought there was something
something identifiably gay about your
shows is there maybe you know I wouldn't
say we're necessarily strictly LGBT TV
but I do think there may be a
sensibility but that often gets defined
or characterized as gay
I wouldn't necessarily characterize it
as gay I would say it is exuberant or it
is unafraid to be eccentric it is
celebratory I think those things often
do
get to consider to be gay but I don't
think that they're inherently gay
characteristics I think what always
excited us about gay people and being
gay is that at some point you just have
to have the balls or the you're just
gonna live your life the way you want to
and we've always been drawn to an
admired characters kind of live their
life out loud so out of the closet of
repression it doesn't mean you have to
be gay I consider your shows to be
shameless yes yes and so do you wear
that as a badge of honor absolutely and
why should anyone be ashamed of anything
it's just there's no time for that I
think and you know guilt and shame and
all these sort of negative things you
know we just always and you know what
the thing is about TV it's a small
screen and so you need big large
characters and I sort of think that's
what life's about - it's not about you
know going round with a bag over your
head being miserable it's like you know
it's it's here and then it's gone it's
it's like a
everybody's like a flower or something
so that's fine you AG but I got it so
most of your shows deal with sex yeah
quite openly yeah why well you know it's
a big it's a big absence on television
it's like sex is a really kind of
important part of who we are you know
like if there were no sacks there would
be no civilization there would be no
society so it's it's kind of the engine
and so it always struck us as odd that
it was never talked about or it was just
invisible on the TV landscape and when
we did it took us 10 years to get
pornography the secret history of
civilization made that was a you know
six-part documentary series because our
idea was that pornography sexually
explicit expression has been this sort
of initiator it's they've been the sort
of Midwife of new mediums and that
whether it's the novel or whether it's
movies whether it was video or whether
it's the internet sexually explicit
expression has been
that sort of initial killer application
that that gets these mediums accepted by
people this is how people get exposed to
to new media and so we thought it was a
really important story to tell it's not
really about getting off but but because
but I think sex is profoundly important
it's extraordinary that we have all this
violence around us but sex is considered
beyond the pale or somehow immoral but
in the sea isn't I'm very curious about
porn I mean a lot of people see it as at
best just sort of a release from the
repression of our society do you see it
as anything more than that that's not
official that's no I think pornography
is like it's almost like the first
expression of documentary filmmaking I
mean it's real what you're seeing when
these porn stars are going at it that
they're actually doing it there's not a
body double it's not they're not but
they may be faking it but they're faking
it while they're doing it I think it's
fascinating the the way in which
pornography is a kind of documentary
experience it's a sort of reality TV
experience and I think what's
interesting in America certainly is that
pornography has been allowed to exist as
a business as a transactional thing as a
way to do you pay your money and you get
off but it hasn't been allowed to exist
as a as something worthy of discussion
it hasn't had a place at the cultural
table and that is when people get really
upset and angry they're fine with the
porn does go buy your porn and jerk off
but the idea that Paul would have any
more importance that's what gets people
upset when we were making inside deep
throat we went on a campus to get the
views of young people you know and the
faculty Gehman shut us down but all
those students were downloading porn
looking at porn using consuming
pornography but what upset them was the
idea that anyone would talk about it and
I do think pornography has been
incredibly important you know even now
when we've reached a point actually
where the pornography business almost in
a way is ceasing to exist because the
Internet
great democratizer of absolutely
everything has has meant that now people
just do their own porn and they put
their own porn up and there's no real
need for a porn industry the way the way
though that it used to exist many of
your shows are about celebrity right
you've had a very long relationship with
RuPaul yeah can you talk about that talk
about the history of it how it started
the moment Rani Rani and I were in
Atlanta and performing and that's a
whole other story but we saw RuPaul on
the streets of Atlanta and he was a
wheat pasting he's putting up Bills of
himself
and they just said RuPaul is everything
and we were like this guy's a star I
mean and he always was a star it was
just the rest of the world kind of had
to catch up I mean he was a black drag
queen yeah who became a mainstream star
yeah how do you explain that well you
think that drag is I think people get
caught up on the idea that's men
dressing up as women I yes technically
but that's not really what it is I think
it's it's this presentation of self it
is this sort of it is this art form and
whether it's someone like Lee by Ari or
RuPaul what drag is is it's a commentary
on the culture it's a sort of satire or
a pastiche of consumer celebrity culture
and so people think it's taboo or
forbidden because it's men dressing up
as women well you know women have
dressed up as men for hundreds of years
without anyone paying any attention so I
don't see why it's such a taboo that a
man should dress as a woman and I think
it is this it has this larger
significance it is this commentary it is
this way you can you can comment on the
culture and talk about the culture so
RuPaul's Drag Race it's entering its
sixth season a big hit on logo and on
vh1 why is it become so successful a
reality show about drag queens competing
with one another I know right it's like
it I think it's it's it's irresistible
exuberance I do think that we do lead
fairly repressed button-down lives and
along comes the drag queen and says [ __ ]
all that you know and they take
everything and turn it into something I
I think that's the other thing it's just
sort of alchemy that idea that you
without a lot of money just a little bit
of imagination you can create something
out of nothing that you can just
reinvent yourself and I think it's that
fundamental appeal of dressing up that
really you know even if you're someone
who goes to work in a suit and says well
I don't do that anymore you probably
have dressed up for Halloween once or
twice and enjoyed that experience it's a
very very sort of fundamental fun thing
to do and I think it's also empowering
to try on different roles and assume
different personas it's it's kind of
like what life is about and I sort of so
I think there's something very pure
about why it appeals to people I think
the other thing is that this is a show
that is itself a show and drag and that
we take the conventions of reality shows
and competition elimination and we put
it all in the hopper and and we parody
it and celebrate it so it's the sort of
show of shows you know that's that's why
we love making it and hope that people
like watching it for that too because
you can get a sort of commentary on
everything that's on TV and in pop
culture when you watch dragons so so
should there be any rules apply it to
television should there should there be
an FCC none at all no it was a terrible
mistake
you have a son yeah and you're fine with
him watching anything until oh no no I'm
not but I'm the parent and so I get to
say what he should and should not watch
I don't need the FCC to to regulate that
for me you know and he's he doesn't
really watch TV
he's on YouTube all the time and typing
in Lego so he wants to watch Lego trains
and and I have to make sure that it's a
Lego trains crashing not real trains
crashing because you know just if you
forget to put in Lego you're suddenly
like looking at you know pretty horrific
things but I think it's C I think it's
okay
what about sex do you want him to watch
pornography would that be okay well I
think it it's up to him to watch
pornography when he's old enough to
appreciate it I mean I I imagine he will
I don't know that well it's sort of I
don't know that I'll really have a role
in I don't think you should watch
pornography while he's a child and like
I don't think he should see violent
things but you know often we're watching
TV at breakfast and I'm like you cannot
watch this like what they say on the
news I'm like it's not fit for a child I
feel to to here is that about the
violence that we WordPress yeah well
actually celebrate violence we it's fine
for children to watch so we have
violence but we not so happy with them
watching sex high time we have this sort
of porn violence on breakfast TV every
morning like so we should abolish the
FCC yeah yeah yeah I mean really yeah
YouTube it doesn't it doesn't people
aren't really watching TV I mean young
people aren't watching TV so much that
anyway they're watching YouTube and the
FCC doesn't really exist in terms of
YouTube so in a way it's taking care of
itself and you've seen American
civilization go into the gutter because
of that right well you know we all you
know I think the problems we have a not
really related to drag queens being on
TV really I thought you were the cause
of our problem there are other causes at
work here so what do you think of PBS ah
yeah speaking of the government yeah
determining what we want yeah I know I
the thing about PBS is you know as a
viewer tuning in to watch it is it's
just dull and I'm sorry I think that's
inexcusable
I don't think TV should be dull I think
you know anytime you tell a story
whether you are a writer or a filmmaker
or a recording artist or in TV you have
a an obligation or some sort of
responsibility we don't have it you have
to but if you want to tell a story and
you want people to listen to your story
and if you don't want people to listen
to your story why even tell it so we
assume
telling a story you want an audience I
think that means you have some
obligation to draw the audience in and I
watch PBS and it's pushing the audience
away why is that why do you think PBS is
so boring I suppose because it thinks
it's better than the people that are
watching it and I think that's a fatal
mistake some people it's the Pro it's
the highbrow problem some people have
said where we are paying for the elites
entertainment right through taxes right
well it's worse than England where
you've got the BBC where everybody's
paying you know a vast fortune in the
form of license fee to be educated and
entertained so I want to talk about sort
of contemporary gay politics for a
second and I think you and I might have
some differences here but we've we've
had a couple of small skirmishes about
this I think on Facebook maybe you know
I mean there's the argument which I'm
sympathetic to that gay marriage has
been always a conservative movement that
it was intended to as Andrew Sullivan
put it in gay culture right and and you
see that in a lot of ways I mean there's
sort of an assimilationist piece of it
right so in fact many of the proponents
of gay marriage called for banning drag
queens from pride marches in San
Francisco and Miami and elsewhere and
now that hasn't happened entirely but
you know is there if if guests are
getting married and having children and
being just like us right you know I mean
will America lose something well no I
don't think so I mean you know there's
look there's all kinds of gay people
we're not all sort of wig wearing
high-heeled wearing radical subversives
I mean I applaud the Queen's at
Stonewall who picked up a brick and
threw it at the police I mean they
really you may think a drag queen as
some sort of Fey figure but drag queens
are fierce they are you know they're
like the Marines
I think but but but not all gay people
are drag queens our drag queens like the
Marines that they're the toughest of the
bunch I mean it wasn't you know if it
wasn't for Stonewall if it wasn't for
them picking
bricks the it wouldn't be a gay
liberation we wouldn't be where we are
today and I do think that you know
someone once said to me sometimes you've
got to pick up a [ __ ] rock and
that's what the drag queens did anyway
not all gay people are drag queens you
know and I think that some gay people do
want to get married and and have kids
but that doesn't mean the end of gay
culture if anybody if any of those
people want to ban drag queens pride
parades well you know that's that's kind
of that's their loss and you're always
hearing complaints from people that the
fist [ __ ] and the drag queens are
always ruining for everyone else because
they give gay people such a bad name but
here's the point the whole idea of being
gay is it is kind of like a rainbow of
different people so if you are gay you
can't start legislating about what's too
gay or not gay enough and of course you
know there are gay bullies just like the
straight bullies and there are gay
stupid people just like the straight
stupid people so I think that you I
personally believe that you have to have
the drag queens and the fists [ __ ] at
the parade and you should because the
moment you start saying no you're
creating some kind of you know trying to
create your own sort of elite society
and the whole point about being gay is
is kind of everybody's gay you know not
necessarily in terms of sexual
orientation but that sense of being a
minority of one I think everybody is a
little bit gay and so being gay is not
about excluding people and so if you
want to get married I think I think it's
very important that we should have the
exact same rights as everybody else do
you want to get married sort of thought
about it talked about it talking about
talking to my partner about it we're
talking about it right now
I you know part of me does yeah I want
the I want the same yeah yeah I mean my
but personally my upbringing was well
you can be gay that's fine but you can't
get married and you can't have kids and
I always thought well why not why why
not why do I fight if I'm gay and
special where do I have to live over
here in this box where I can't be
married and I can't have kids like there
must be something wrong with being gay
that you aren't allowed those things so
if you get married yeah will you stop
making RuPaul's Drag Race absolutely not
like then we're fine all right so I have
one last question I want to know whether
or not Alex our cameraman and I are the
only straight male fans of RuPaul's Drag
Race
well first thought you're both gay I
know that's why everybody's a little bit
gay like I can t be boo said right
didn't she say that yeah I think she did
great civil rights leader honey boo boo
and but also there's a huge female
audience for drag race hmm and I can't
imagine it they're all gay I don't think
I don't think you have to be in the
least bit gay to enjoy drag race
personally I can guarantee that thank
you
although I guess I am gay so well I
think we're gonna have to leave it there
for today I want to thank Fenton Bailey
for joining us today
for reason TV I'm Thad Russell